[Music]
Emma Watson reveals Tom Hanks lives up
to his nice-guy reputation she's like
all lightness and love Petey spoke with
the 27 year old actress at the Tribeca
Film Festival on Wednesday where she
opened up about working with the
legendary actor on their new film the
circle out April 28 is like you know you
just think to yourself there's no way
this guy is gonna live up to his
reputation and then he does and it's all
right not really no he's funny and kind
and generous to work with and very
hard-working and he's all the things we
care about everybody you care about is
there anything you want to tell us I
think that's what is so amazing about
his performances in this is that like
there's something so unexpected about it
and and yeah he's like all lightness and
love and light on the outside but
there's something else yeah
good or bad that's in the eye of the
beholder Emma also shared what it was
like working with the late actor Bill
Paxton who starred in the film alongside
she and Tom you know it's wonderful
working with him um it was a really
personal relationship for me
[Music]
you